let's just uh
jump off the the metaphorical cliff with
this next article from politico they
write we are in a new civil war about
what exactly grievous conflicts have
been about big things war slavery
depression but this time we just don't
like each other spoken like a true
establishment democrat personality who
doesn't know anything about the right or
moderates or libertarians or
post-liberals this article says to me oh
they've recognized there's anger there's
a conflict but they're so ignorant to
what's been going on they think we just
don't like each other
that to me is absolutely incredible let
me just start with
barack obama killed children let's uh uh
national defense authorization act and
definite detention provision uh
spying nsa spying um the prosecution of
journalists and whistleblowers and then
let's move on to uh more more towards
the end uh hillary clinton deleting 30
000 emails getting away with it and the
establishment lying and protecting how
about this russia gate ukraine gate the
covington kids over and over benghazi
lies benghazi afghanistan
now i can complain about the things
trump did with the commando raids in
yemen and the drone strikes upping the
drone strikes missile strikes in syria
too and i can tell you
we i i think most people in this country
are pissed off at the establishment for
those reasons and many many more but
what do they say
we just don't like each other no no you
don't know
this faction of the establishment zombie
npcs they don't they just hate they hate
or they're ignorant they don't read they
don't care to learn and they don't want
to hear what you have to say but the
conflict we are seeing bubble up from i
guess the american populists be it
moderate left and right then you have
the establishment left there's real
reasons why there's a conflict happening
yeah i think i think that that's true
but the lay man the average american
they hate each other and don't even know
why
people people hate their neighbors and i
i agree with you to a certain degree
because i do think that there's reasons
why but a lot of people cannot even
articulate the reason why they don't
like trump why do you think it is where
do you think it comes from people are
dumb we've been dumbed down through
technology through the school system
people are they're such sheep and maybe
we've always been this way but this is
what i'm saying right
you ask the average trump supporter do
you watch trump speak they'll probably
say yes
and that's why they they like him how
many people have we heard they used to
be democrats and then they decided to
vote for trump after they actually
listened to the man
they what what the media had done the
establishment with articles like this
what are we mad about exactly
they don't tell their audience what's
really happening they show trump in the
worst possible light i saw a reddit post
and it was like one of the top posts and
it said for the life of me i don't
understand why this wasn't the end of it
and it was a picture of trump doing the
arm thing and it said trump mock's
disabled reporter they set trump up with
that and if you actually watch the video
trump supporters said trump insults
everyone in the same way saying oh geez
oh geez it has nothing to do with the
reporter in general when you realize
that trump insults everybody that way
you're like oh he's just an [ __ ] it
wasn't directed at one disabled guy but
the media lied about it yeah then all of
a sudden you're like okay i get it he's
kind of a dick but what is he saying and
then you actually listen to what he has
to say and you're like wow the media
told me he was a white supremacist now
it turns out he just wants to bring
factories back
all of a sudden people vote for him i
just kind of want to add a little bit to
your point that you were making in the
beginning i i think it's fair to
acknowledge that the establishment has
been screwing over the average person
for a very long time whether it's the
wars the banker bailouts the hyper money
printing there's a lot of problems that
are artificially created for the benefit
of the ruling elite in the united states
that screws over the average american
and then they have the gall to say it's
his fault and they're doing this with
social conditioning they're doing this
with the algorithms they're doing this
with trauma-based mind control and
emotional manipulation and they're
saying all of your problems that we
caused how we we laced you we skinned
you we screwed you over your neighbor's
the problem and and some people are
actually believing it and buying that
bag of lies and and to me this is why
we're such we're so close towards this
conflict which again we should do
everything in our power to try to avoid
sorry you had something to say as well
one more point real quick sorry um i
just want to reiterate a point that we
brought up on a couple other shows
lauren beaubert
made fun of biden for saying true nana
shaba to pressure when he when he had
that gaff she said biden has never
fulfilled his promise of getting us true
nana shabbat of pressure or whatever and
the response from the democrat activist
base was
what is she trying to say her brain is
finally rotted oh no look how dumb she
is was she what was she trying to type
they didn't know joe biden said that
because they don't watch the news
and politico and cnn these outlets don't
inform them of what's actually going on
so they live in this bubble world echo
chamber where they hate everyone outside
of it and the people outside of it you
know acros beyond the fire have seen all
the different aspects of reality in the
nuance that's the conflict can we play
the true and honor shadow of the
pressure at some point well i'll pull it
up while you you you know you hit the
nail on the head because that's how i
became republican and why i voted for
trump is because i want to win his
rallies now first and foremost i'm
open-minded and that's what people need
to get to the point where they can say
let me open my mind up and hear both
sides of an argument before i make a
decision but i went to a rally a trump
rally and i think it was 2015 2016 and i
went in there and he was supposed to be
this racist dude throwing black people
out of his rallies for no reason
illegally all this sort of stuff i went
there and the dude was cool
he was saying all the things that i
believe i'm like and he and he did it
with passion he did it
authentically all of the above and then
i found out that he wasn't throwing
people out of his events illegally he
was buying or renting these spaces um as
a private event and you can in a private
event you can ask people to leave and if
they refuse to leave they can be
arrested for trespassing that's what he
did he gave an announcement before every
rally that he did and all of that blew
my mind as a police officer and i said
you know what these people are lying
and i'll say this too about the
republicans is that the republicans need
to do a good job at recruiting and
converting but they don't they but but
the republicans don't do the converting
the democrats do i didn't become i
didn't become a republican because of
republicans i came to kevin because he
crazy democrats all of my friends all my
dad everybody
they go so crazy these leftists they go
so wacky that it pushed people away and
then they end up going to the other side
would you start a new political party uh
it's too late yeah it's too late because
you know you still have people in this
country that are rational right
there's the radical and then there's the
rational people and i think a lot of
rational people still have rational
ideas within the republican party and
believe that it could actually
um be
you know rescued like if you get another
party it just you're going to split the
vote i'm going to try i want to play
this clip just real quick effective
strategy to mobilize true international
depression i'll need an effective
strategy to mobilize true international
depression
i want that cheering afterwards
it's the way the crowd cheers after he
says it's like this cult of like they
don't even know what he said but they're
like yeah that's another thing i was
like when he says trinidad shabbat to
pressure whatever and batacaf care
everyone goes yeah
it's like why they're cheering just for
the fact that he made a noise it doesn't
even matter what he said they don't even
know that's usually politics
of pressure i mean the guy the guy is
showing early signs of mental
deterioration i mean it's not even a
joke i mean the fact that he's stumbling
over his words he
he talks straight he don't know where
he's at half of the time this proves
that the president is not in charge this
proves that someone else is calling the
shots that's from my perspective that's
how i see it that's my opinion i know we
disagree and we and we can maybe we can
debate this later but evidence maybe no
no no no no hold on it's a good point
luke i disagree with you i think your
opinion is valid in my opinion
i think he's sitting at the table
whacked out of his mind kamala harris
doesn't care and he's telling people we
gotta you know
he's he's in this like the situation
room you got libya
come on man and then they're like okay
and they'll look around at each other
and they're like you got it and they
walk out of the room like what do we do
like withdrawals
let's just move some ships around and
then they do like i think
joe biden is just muttering and
sputtering and they just say
when you look at kamala harris not going
to the border
that's i don't think that's an issue of
by not running the show i think it's an
issue of them being like i don't know
man i don't care biden says she's the
borders aren't she's like i ain't doing
it what's he he's not he's gonna forget
so i don't care thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you